so you know every time you go into a new
year the key is to have a certain
mindset like if you were to choose a
word for a year or a couple words for
the year what would it be today i was
watching a video that mario shared with
me
it's a talk i gave in 2015 when i was
living in an rv for 30 days going from
la to miami to new york to niagara falls
to san francisco back to l.a and this is
a stop at i believe san bernardino
valley
and we're there and i'm giving this talk
and it was probably one of the best ones
i give out of the 16 stops that i i had
and the message while i'm listening to
it i'm getting emotional listen to the
five year younger path given the message
here at 37 years old 36 years old
but you have to hear what mindset it is
that hopefully you will take going into
2020. i'm not going to show you the
whole talk because it's 23 minutes
but i'm gonna just show you a three four
five minute segment of a speech i gave
while i was on san bernardino so let's
take a look at this here together you
ever met bitter people anybody met
bitter
depressed people do you ever wonder why
some of us sometimes are so bitter and
depressed
i used to want to find out what causes
people to be lazy
until i figured out why people are lazy
i wanted to find that at one point
why am i so lazy when i was a kid do you
know it's a very simple research does
anybody know what causes laziness
a boring life boredom
is the seed of laziness when we watch a
boring movie what happens to
us we fall asleep when you watch an
exciting movie what happens to us
we don't fall asleep that's your life if
your life is boring you're lazy
if your life doesn't have a lot of
action you don't have a lot of energy
and i saw that in my life but you know
what causes bitterness
and what causes depression you haven't
met bitter people that everything to
them is like
they're so bitter to be around do you
know what it is let me tell you what
causes happiness
and what causes bitterness and here's
all it is people who no longer create
anything are depressed and bitter
and people who continuously create
they're happy
watch let me give you an example tell us
my mom and dad divorced in 1989
20 years they didn't see each other my
mom told me i would never be in the same
with your dad my dad said i would never
see your mom
ever again 20 years i prayed i wanted to
have them to be in the same room
together
20 years later they did you know why
because my niece was born
my sister created a child when she
created that child
everybody showed up and everybody was
happy
my mom and dad talked to each other with
no problems how many times you seen
grandkids bring families together
anybody's ever seen grandkids what they
do to a family everyone shows up out of
nowhere
if we don't create we're not happy
you see people who are bitter make a
list of what they've been creating
nothing they're not happy they don't
have happiness
there's not fulfillment there anybody's
ever bought anything from ikea
you ever bought anything from ikea do
you ever realize like afterwards what
the heck was i
thinking about going to this ikea my
wife i come on babe
yeah baby see that box
yeah baby what's your point with the box
you know when we said we're gonna make
that show we're gonna make that
that that that little cabinet together
today babe
we never make it together you just hand
me the screwdriver baby i mean that's
not making it together
so then you go over there you're all
ticked off man you know what i'm talking
about guys you
so we go over there like this talking
behind you know under on their own
same stuff and you look at the box 198
parts and and you open the manual it's
in french i don't speak french like give
me an
english manual and you start filming
this thing
right and you're so furious and you're
getting close to what
finishing it and then your masterpiece
is done
and then your parents show up hey mom i
created that thing
i am the creator of that thing
son don't touch it i created it
do not touch it hey hey john you know
that thing right there i created it
i did it ikea has become a multi-billion
dollar company
because they figured out people become
happy when they create things
so dooku game is good because when you
create and finish the diabolic formula
whatever it is
you're all happy you know what i'm
puzzles we create we're happy
but those are just actions that don't
make you money
another thing we've realized we need is
a community we need to be part of a
community you know who learned that
instagram
facebook you know what we do nowadays
here's what we do hey
give me the deductions five and a half
years ago by the way five and a half
years ago this is
a 15 hashtag hashtag
okay it's like a pic man what was a good
bad one i was gonna blow up watch
they say 150 times a day we look at this
thing 150 a lot higher today we go
oh bro 17 likes in four minutes
whoo it's good it's good oh my god this
is good
oh did you walk around i'll check it
again
34. we're on track for having the best
one my best one is 68.
69 likes whoa instagram
how come jerry didn't like the picture
how weird are we right because we need a
community
you know what's the last one you know
what's the last one this is why
russian empire failed miserably and the
country finally went to gorbachev and
said
get the heck out of here communism
doesn't work do you know why it doesn't
work as much as they're trying to
convince americans it works
do you know why it doesn't work do you
know why it doesn't work
because we love having a sense of
ownership
we have to have ownership when anybody's
been to a game and your kid scores a
touchdown what does a parent typically
do
hey hey hey i'm sorry did you see that
that's my boy
so he runs like his daddy he's kind of
like you know he's an actor like his
father
how are you i know i'm kind of gain
weight but that was that was me 30 32
years ago
son i'm proud of you buddy that's my son
hey whose wife is this it's my wife why
why are you looking at her
i look at my wife it's my wife my my
wife
whose husband is that's my husband don't
don't don't you be looking at my husband
over there i'm telling us my husband
right there okay
get your highest offer hey whose lawn is
it get off my
lawn whose house is this whose car is
this
my you know why because we need to have
a sense of honesty
you know what's crazy let me tell you
what's crazy create community sense of
ownership
is all the activities that create
happiness for female meaningful life
do you know all entrepreneurs do all day
long
is create they're part of a community
and they own their business
that's why i'm gonna stop right here
that's about five minutes right there
you can go watch the rest but
three words for you to be thinking about
going into 2021
create meaning stay in creation mode
this year
create create what create momentum
create
opportunities create unknowns stay in
creation mode the entire year especially
in december with momentum going into
number two find the right community look
i can guarantee you one thing here
wherever you are in your life right now
there's because a community you're part
of i don't know what community you're a
part of
i don't know who's around you i i don't
know who in your community challenges
you
i don't know who in your community lifts
you up yesterday we had a meeting at
marjano i held a meeting with all my
directors here at the home office and i
told them that we were
reading a book together called no rules
rules and everybody's like why are you
recommending this book here to me
because in the book it's very
challenging for the co to recommend a
book like that because
in the book it tells employees to go
shop your salaries
so we're sitting there talking and i say
let me ask am i opening a question for
everybody
let me ask you a question are you guys
surprised at why i recommended this book
to you
everybody started laughing yeah we have
no why would you recommend this right
now
i said because if we're going to go into
with the vision to be able to we have a
very big vision that we want to do
we have to upgrade i have to upgrade if
i have to upgrade you want to upgrade
and everybody started giving their
feedback and it's a community so
we're in creation mode we have a
community and last but not least
we take ownership in what we do 2021
take ownership
your losses take ownership you know one
of the quotes i read
in a recent book i read it said
whisper your successes shout your
failures right
failures meaning what i failed i made a
mistake i screwed up
you know it was a terrible mistake i
could have done it better what if i did
it this way
yeah we won but we got a great team and
our team really came through and they
did their part
but let me tell you about the 19
mistakes i made in 2020
let me tell you about the 13 mistakes i
made in 2020 stay in creation mode
find the right community sense of
ownership for everything you do
take ownership of the things that's
going to happen for you in 2021
you'll be surprised what's going to
happen to you uh with the results you'll
get i remember when i shifted to this
mindset years ago
it you know 90 days later i couldn't
even recognize my life
there was a certain peace of mind i had
because i just kind of knew everything
was going to work out for me i remember
one day i'm at my house in granada hills
my dad's right there we're roommates
this is ninth this is 2002
2003 mbna calls me because i owe them 5
800 bucks and i haven't paid them
nothing for six months because i'm broke
but i'm working my ass off and i'm in
creation mode
i'm in the right community i'm taking
ownership of all my faults
they call me i pick up hey how you doing
great i joke with them i said listen i
know why you're calling me i want to pay
it off he said what do you mean
i don't have any money right now but i'm
telling you i'm busting my ass i'm going
to pay you guys off
you don't have to worry about me filing
bankruptcy you don't have to be worried
about doing anything
just stop bothering me so i can get to
work so i can pay you off the guy starts
laughing i say you'll see i'm gonna call
you and pay you off
six twelve months later hey how you
doing what's going on
i'm ready to pay off and i paid off why
creation
community sense of ownership
life-changing
if you haven't watched this entire
speech i gave here it's called the dna
of an entrepreneur click over here to
watch the whole thing
and uh i challenge and encourage you to
what you hear here
and put it in like internalize it for
your own self write it down
put it all over your phone make
reminders and then go into 2021
with the kind of momentum you've never
had in your life in the month of
december
and then in 2021 it could potentially be
the beginning of the greatest years of
your life